thank you guys thank you
uh
me and my teammates just want to tell
you guys thank you so much
for the opportunity to play in front of
you guys this year
thank you for sticking with us each and
every day each night when we're on the
road and we're at home as well here at
the bank so we just want to tell you
guys thank you we got uh today and six
more six more big ones so hopefully
we're back here october 11th
if you guys wave in your flags and your
towels and uh we bring back october
baseball so we got a big week ahead and
uh thank you so much
and there is hans krause who the
phillies acquired from the texas rangers
in the spencer howard deal
the first pitch of krause's big league
career
he's hit in the air to right field that
is well struck
and it is
i can't
i cannot believe
first pitch of a pitcher's career i
guess he figured he was getting a
fastball unbelievable
so that puts two on with two outs here
in the first and it brings kevin newman
up
and a high fly ball to left field
mccutcheon's there he's got room he's
under it waits the win brings it back
even a little bit more and the inning is
over hans krauss
allows a home run to the first hitter he
faced on the first pitch of his big
league career max crannicks in just 29
innings almost 32 thirds
one two pitches a line drive to right
coming on and making a sliding grab
yoshi tsutsugo into that first slide
nice jump there from yoshi coming in to
get that ball i mean that's kind of like
a split decision you start in right away
you rob a herrera of a hit bryce harper
had a booming home run in the third
inning
yesterday
and a good pitch from the pitcher right
there craddock everybody fired up struck
out harper
well if you missed that in the zone that
might be right in his back pass so right
to get that down and in like that that
was nice and the 0-1 it's a little
dribbler and scooped by the pirates
pitcher and three-quarters of the way to
first base he casually lops it on to
colin moran for the final out after one
inning in philly it's the pirates one
philly's nothing about a third of the
order due up here against hans krauss
swing of the miss
perez is down on strike's first major
league strikeout for krauts
they get that ball too don't we two outs
cole tucker's coming up
to the right side
segura waits back on it and throws out
tucker
and it's a clean second inning for hans
krauss
back-to-back two-out walks opening the
door for the pirates to score more yeah
that brings kevin newman up
fly ball out toward right and harper was
playing that way makes the catch the
inning is over so krause does walk a
couple but he gets out of the third no
runs no hits two men left so here's gene
segura
line drive back through the middle of
base sid that almost took off braddock's
arm as he reached for it
and the first hit of the day for the
fills comes off the bat of segora harper
struck out his first time up and he
shoots it the other way and base hit
segora is on his way to third the throw
goes to second first at third with two
men down
and there is a difference in bryce
harper and the bryce harper we've seen
since all-star break right there
that was ball and there was no i'm
hitting this out of here there was no
i'm hitting this out here i was up on
that swing no
that's what makes him so difficult right
now to pitch to because he will do that
tying around 90 feet away as cranic
works to jt real muto here's the 2-2
swing of the miss
he did get him with a slider that's his
third strikeout phillies have left four
through the first three innings today
tucker bats now from the right side his
home run came leading off the ball game
as a lefty hitter
opposite way evasive to right field
perez is around third he's being held
late by cora
you gotta be kidding me there you go the
fear from bryce harper's on eight
outfield assists this year for harper
stops a run with two outs first and
third and here is suzugo lefty on lefty
breaks his bat grounds it out to second
base thank you mr perez
4-3 on the put out side is retired no
runs
one hit two men left all right so that
brings o'double up third time through
the order against craddock duo pitch to
herrera
a spinner off the hands look at that
ball spin like a top out to center field
herrera is thinking about two
he was hesitating but he slides in
safely
yeah that thing just jammed the you know
what out of him and that ball had a lot
of spin good hustle right there by
o'dougal put himself in scoring
positions
agora strikes out it's a quick four
fingers from derek shelton well let's
see if jt can come through here
ball to shortstop newman gobbles it up
goes to second and the inning is over so
crannic is able to throw five shutout
innings today for the pirates please
leave two more
ball four that'll load the bases up so
three walks in the inning for alvarado
brian hayes is going to come up as a
pinch hitter
and a line drive down the right field
line that's a fair ball it's going to
spin to the corner this should clear the
bases moran is around third heading for
home the throw by segora is in time
it's a two-run double for keep ryan
hayes and it's three-nothing pirates
moran there's something going on with
his leg that he can't run all that well
that that obviously should have cleared
the bases but segora's arm made sure he
doused that and now they're going to
intentionally walk neumann the batter is
left-handed hitting michael perez the
catcher
on a high fly ball to right field harper
is going back toward the track toward
the wall makes the catch just a step or
two from the wall a pinch it two-run
double for key ryan hayes
is the only hit in the inning
mark at the plate
got a pitch to hit
out to harper and he doesn't get it
park hustling all the way is going to be
in at second base
that's a great effort out there uh i
know i know what he's thinking right now
i should have had that ball even though
it was a tough play i know he thinks any
ball touches glove he should catch that
loads the bases it's a hit batter and a
walk the bases are loaded for suzuga
who's over four
ground ball and it's through the hole on
the right side trickling into right
field two runs will score park
and offer they throw back behind at
second base and they get cole tucker
second outfield assist of the day for
harper one out i'm not sure tucker
thinks he was out he's looking in the
dugout pirates want to challenge the tag
play at second so tucker's out two runs
though are in five runs on six hits now
for the pirates nick mears now to face
bryce harper to start this bottom of the
eighth with the pitch to harper swing
and a miss yeah you like that match up
like that match-up strikes out price
harper right at him holder has walked
flight out and tried to bunt for a hit
pitch from meers swing and a miss tied
him up and then snatching that pitch out
of the air michael perez batter andrew
mccutchen nick mears with the pitch
swing and a miss mccutcheon goes down on
strikes and mirror strikes out three in
the eighth inning the pitch is up high
all the way to the back stop and that'll
allow the runner to move to third base
and now a ball gun rosso
this has been
as sloppy a game as we've seen in a
while from the phillies
and rosso just put his head down
no right there yeah he did it he knew it
too look at jt toss this one away from
the highlight clip just flip it away
pray for the braves to lose i guess five
straight outs via the strikeout
and six of the last seven outs so here's
veiling
the 2-2
bouncer right side park charges he has
it throws to first in time they lose it
six nothing and now they sit and wait
and see what happens with the with the
braves and the padres and hope they're
within one and a half going into
tuesday's game against atlanta